We know that a mass of 1 kg experiences
a rate force of about 10 Newtons on the surface of the earth,
but for space travel, we need to know more.
What's going to happen if it double the distance
between our mass and the center of the earth?
For instance, what's going to happen if we double
the distance between our mass at the center of the earth?
Obviously, the force is shrinking,
but by which factor?
It turns out that as we double the distance,
we have only one quarter of the force.
If we tripled the distance, the
force goes down to 1/9, which means
that in our creation for the force of gravity,
we have to have a distance squared in the denominator.
If we use twice the mass,
we should have twice the force,
so the mass appears in the numerator.
And if all masses are created equal, the
mass of the earth should have the same role,
so the mass of the earth, too, should appear in the numerator.
>From the units of measurement, you can see
that this doesn't work out so far -- kg²/m²
That doesn't look like force--
this universal constant appearing in front--
the constant of gravity, which is 6.67 * 10⁻¹¹,
N m²/kg².
These units are pretty much of human scale--
Newtons, meters, kilograms--and you see that
gravity seems to be pretty small on these scales.
The force exerted by 2 masses of 1 kg each
in a distance of 1 m
would amount to 6.67 * 10⁻¹¹ Newtons--
a pretty small force.
This is why we need something as big as a planet to see gravity in action.